E aí
[Música]
e
se essa gargalhada se repita várias e
várias vezes ao longo da vida de cada
criança esse Depende de um cérebro feliz
e bem construído esse sonho que move a
minha vida com o neuropediatra
neurocientista professora da Medicina e
mãe de três crianças e Convido você
fazer parte dele com essa mudança de
paradigma cada papai mamãe o pessoa que
vive com crianças deve compreender como
ocorre a formação das estruturas
cerebrais relacionadas a prosperidade EA
felicidade se você sair dessa palestra
refletindo no seu papel em ajudar as
crianças a se tornarem seres humanos
bem-sucedidos na vida com mais
capacidade para criar Inovar refletir e
amar já valeu a pena sabe quem possui
residências para alcançar essas
potencialidades a neurociência nos
últimos anos as pesquisas e do cérebro
humano vem trazer-nos dados
interessantíssimos e cada vez que eu
aprendo algo novo tenho desejo contar
para todo mundo pois esses conhecimentos
precisam ser divulgados e aplicados com
afeto vamos abordar aqui alguns
princípios como
neuroplasticidade mielinização janelas
de oportunidade em neurónios espelho
É sim o futuro de sucesso do planeta
nasce quando cada um de nós é concebido
quando um bebê gerado as expectativas
surge o primeiro tum tum do coraçãozinho
o nome acordo quarto segundo dia ele
nasce que alegria precisa de cuidados
com a amamentação e higiene vacinação
prevenção de doenças e nos dias atuais
para se tornar um bom pai ou uma boa mãe
é preciso também entender como estimular
o desenvolvimento pleno do cérebro da
criança
cerca de noventa porcento do cérebro
humano se forma nos primeiros anos de
vida o que depende da interação da
genética com o ambiente A genética
programas etapas mas é um ambiente O
entorno que criança vive que vai
Executar a formação cerebral
imagine a construção de um Pedro 1º cabo
a ser um buraco ele é construído a
fundação do edifício logo em seguida
para ir se a base concreto Edifício é
construído andar por andar se você
descobre um problema na estrutura quando
o décimo andar não há como voltar e
consertar não é mesmo Isso é o que
acontece com nosso cérebro a fundação da
arquitetura cerebral e construído nos
primeiros anos de vida e deve ser forte
o suficiente para sustentar todos os
demais aprendizados o cérebro começa a
se formar dentro do útero ao Nascimento
já possuímos a maioria dos nossos
bilhões de neurônios mas as conexões
entre eles chamadas sinapses são
incompletas nos primeiros anos de vida
principalmente nos primeiros mil dias
que é o período que vai da Concepção até
dois anos formam-se centenas de sinapses
a cada segundo um segundo centenas de
novas conexões e um neurônio passa se
conectar com até 15 mil outros em um
momento onde Muitos pais estão mais
preocupados em saber qual é a melhor
fralda o que também é uma questão
difícil e o aprendizado de qualquer
habilidade como dar aquela gargalhada
gostosa da Tchau chutaram uma bola no
gol ou escrever seu próprio nome
acontece quando uma rede neural é
formada no cérebro sendo que as mais
simples se formam o primeiro servindo de
suporte para as mais complexas
todos os estímulos ao redor visuais
auditivos de sensações entram em nosso
corpo e gera uma descarga elétrica no
cérebro quanto mais é repetido existimos
mas ele vai ativando a mesma via e ela
se torna então duradoura formando uma
rede neural as vias que não forem
ativadas Não sofrerá poda neuronal e
serão Perdidas com um ano temos mil
trilhões de sinapses e aos 20 anos a uma
redução parcial
permanecendo as que foram mais repetidas
Então quem conhece Esse princípio da
neurociência passa escolher de forma
consciente uma rotina que quem palavras
hábitos e atitudes adequadas e deixar a
criança na frente da tela o dia inteiro
não é então uma boa estratégia para que
ela aprenda diferentes habilidades ou
dizer isso menina nervoso esse menino é
preguiçoso de forma repetida vai criar
um rótulo forte no cérebro dele o
cérebro funciona melhor com comando
positivo Esse menino é muito capaz ele
sempre se esforça isso cria uma rede
neural de percepção forte de se sentir
capaz e melhora autoestima com Live mais
gargalhadas ao longo da vida e a
neuroplasticidade quanto mais jovens
maior a neuroplasticidade que a
capacidade do cérebro de moldar-se
adaptar-se Diante do estilo Assim começa
as massinhas que adoramos usar quando
novinhos e que com o tempo vão ficando
mais duras de moldar as mãos são os
estímulos ambientais se forem de
qualidade o resultado será perfeito como
aproveitar a neuroplasticidade as
Pesquisas mostram que a resposta é a
reciprocidade o cérebro a princesa de
experiências com respostas estáveis e
previsíveis emocionalmente porém a maior
parte dos adultos se sente muito ocupado
para parar e responder a criança
adultos que já ouviram falar dessa parte
da neurociência se esforçam para
conectar-se de forma genuína com os
pequenos Pois é isso vale mais que
pagaram melhor escola bilíngue ou
comprar o celular mais atual por exemplo
não precisa dizer não para tudo não pode
tocar não pode subir no escorregador de
baixo para cima não Pode respirar antes
de dizer ou não pare e pense que ele
está explorando o mundo como mini
cientista que precisa de experiências
diferentes para ativar a
neuroplasticidade e assim formar a sua
arquitetura cerebral se não se tratar de
uma situação de risco proibitivo diga
não ao seu próprio não de a criança
oportunidade de vivenciar diferença
experiências de forma empolgante quando
criança emitiu um som olha nos olhos lhe
dei atenção responda a Rosa demonstra
está realmente interessado por ela
brinque Sorria a colha resultado mais e
mais gargalhadas feliz e o conceito de
janela de oportunidade ou período
sensitivo sabe quando a gente acorda
abre a janela e tudo se ilumina esse é o
efeito da janela de oportunidade no
nosso cérebro um período onde aquela
área específica está aberto aguardando
receber estímulos para se aperfeiçoar de
forma plena e acelerado áreas diferentes
amadurecem em períodos distintos quando
termina o período sensitivo de uma
função essa parte do cérebro fica
estabilizada e não é possível
reprogramar lá nem aprender com tanta
qualidade por isso nossos pais e
cuidadores precisamos acertar de
primeira como compreendendo que cuidar
de uma criança não vai deixar lá
aprendendo sozinha Enquanto estamos
muito ocupados com as nossas obrigações
Vou esperar o momento de ir para escola
para ela aprender no desenvolvimento do
cérebro da criança não pode a as janelas
vão se fechar deve ser prioridade a
janela da linguagem por exemplo está
aberta nos primeiros três anos de vida
como mostra essa figura e o cérebro é
capaz de aprender qualquer idioma do
planeta no Brasil o bebê escuta
nos Estados Unidos e o ar só um
pouquinho e o aprendizado da língua será
efetivo por isso que devemos conversar
com os filhos principalmente desde bebês
quem tente da importância dos estímulos
oferecidos para amadurecimento cerebral
passa atuar de forma diferente com os
pequenos a neurociência comprova que
quanto mais palavras a criança escuta
desde a gestação melhor a passagem
comunicação alfabetização de
inteligência de aprendizado de outras
línguas e vários artigos comprovam que
falar usando manhãs e o papai e sim
aquele jeito mais doce possuem maior
efetividade
mamãe te ama também ler além de contar
histórias diariamente com expressões e
falas de boa entonação em um momento
Alegre é uma ferramenta poderosa a
formação do circuito básico servirá de
alicerce para todos os demais na vida ou
seja falar Papa vai servir de alicerce
para depois papai me empresta o carro aí
para o namorado então se você oferece
estímulos sexto na fase que a janela de
oportunidade está aberta o aprendizado
será de excelência com nas gargalhadas
agora mielinização lembra quando
passamos uma fita isolante no fio e a
condução se torna melhor esse é o papel
da mielina uma capa que envolve os
axônios que são como fios que conectam
os neurônios e tem o papel de ajudar na
condução dos impulsos nervosos o cérebro
vai ser minimizamos posterior para
anterior e aqui as áreas já minimizadas
aparecem em azul e observe que a última
região será o lobo frontal responsável
pelo segmento adultos que nunca ouviram
sobre essa parte na neurociência que e
as Crianças de igual para igual não dá
seu cérebro ainda imaturo estável Pronta
para sair para deixar minha filha de 2
anos na escola e para uma importância
reunião quando eu fui pegar a mochila no
quarto e voltei ela tinha pego o meu
batom de longa fixação e passou em todo
o seu rosto ainda limpar um pouquinho na
roupa a resposta imediata seria brigar
mas respirei abaixa aí na altura do seu
olhar e pensei como a minha filha
compreende essa situação aos dois anos
de idade percebi que ela estava sorrindo
e disso mamãe igual a você e logo tratei
de fazer um semblante bem calmo e Alegre
disse ficou linda se linha vou até tirar
uma foto uma situação comum as famílias
exigirem que crianças e adolescentes têm
uma capacidade saber por si só que não
devem exceder o tempo de uso de saudável
do celular televisão e videogame e cá
para nós muito dos adultos também não
sabem por isso todos os dias você
precisa repetir para criança e
adolescente Oi tá na hora vamos desligar
a tela e curtir a família com outra
atividade
Exerça autoridade com afeto resultado
nas gargalhadas
Pesquisas mostram que desde
recém-nascido temos a capacidade de
imitar algumas expressões faciais e
também de bocejar quando alguém eu faço
o nosso lado e que isso ocorre devido à
ativação dos chamados neurônios-espelho
agora entendemos científicamente que
realmente um exemplo vale mais que mil
palavras
já vivenciei várias vezes situações no
momento de partilhar com pais e mães a
importância da harmonia nos diálogos
geralmente eles irão para o filho com
expressão facial de raiva e tom de voz
tem esse dize tá vendo eu já disse isso
meu filho pela resposta automática de
ativação dos neurônios-espelho falta de
amadurecimento das áreas relacionadas ao
discernimento o filho imita e responde
com a mesma postura não tô nem aí o pai
diz viu Doutora é desse e sim eu entendi
o cérebro dele está imitando o seu agora
quando lembramos dos Pais
neurônios-espelho nos esforçamos para
ensinar para os pequenos que é um ano
sentir raiva e frustração mas que
podemos manifestar os sentimentos da
forma que escolhemos na raiva podemos
escolher gritar ou respirar e expressar
de forma calma seja você o modelo de
comportamento que deseja para criança
quando estava coçando uma parte no meu
doutorado em Harvard Recebi um convite
para um evento sobre Toxic stress stress
tóxico do que se tratava não podia
perder quando eu cheguei lá estava o
presidente da academia americana de
Pediatria o Jackson cobre que é um
cientista que possui várias publicações
sobre Desenvolvimento Infantil e um
representante da Casa Branca naquela
reunião tive um desejo imenso de
divulgar tudinho no Brasil entende que
para cuidar do potencial cerebral de
cada criança é preciso evitar que ela
seja submetida a eventos adversos que
que os sinos elevados podem levar à
liberação excessiva de hormônios de
estresse como adrenalina e cortisol
resultando em diminuição das regiões
cerebrais O que é chamado de stress
tóxico e socorrem filhos de pais
usuários de drogas que sofrem abuso
sexual e também naqueles Lagos onde são
frequentes conflitos familiares graves
de vossos conturbados agressões físicas
etapas recorrentes e agressões verbais
tudo isso acarreta perda de conexões
cerebrais em um período onde elas
deveriam estar se formando pensei tanta
gente acredita que essa é a melhor forma
de Educar EA neurociência está mostrando
o contrário veja-se neurônio normal e
esse de um indivíduo que sofreu estresse
todos os efeitos da redução das conexões
são irreversíveis evitar o estresse
talks que proporcionaram um ambiente
rico em estímulos positivos é essencial
desde a concepção uma série publicada na
revista the lancet em 2007 mostrou que
200 milhões de crianças dos países em
desenvolvimento Como Perder um potencial
cerebral que possuem ao Nascimento
devido à má nutrição falta de estímulos
adequados e presença de stress tóxico
nos primeiros anos de vida todos fatores
evitáveis baseado nisso surgiu o projeto
neurociência com afeto vivenciamos junto
com pais e mães de bebês em
vulnerabilidade social as estações de
música leitura atividades motoras
nutrição e carinho como brincadeiras
repletos de olhar Encantado sorrisos e
reciprocidade o cérebro inundado por
hormônios do prazer com a criação de
redes neurais fortes e duradouras E mais
sucesso ao longo da vida a neurociência
mostra que criança e adolescente possui
se manual de instrução ele é revelado
quando é uma conexão verdadeira com amor
para entender Quem é esse pequeno ser
humano e quais são as suas necessidades
em cada etapa de desenvolvimento a
neuroplasticidade ela é maior nos
primeiros meses mas ainda bem elevada
até o final da adolescência por isso Boa
tarde para cuidar do cérebro mesmo aos
dois meses dois anos hoje 16 anos e aqui
eu lhe digo isso é bom para crianças
como também para nós adultos pois se nos
atentarmos as a esses pontos nos
tornaremos pessoas melhores a cada dia
aprendo diariamente com os meus três
filhos que amo tanto e com cada criança
e adolescente que cruzam pela minha vida
e tem imensa gratidão por cada um deles
Platão já dizia é possível descobrir
mais sobre uma pessoa em uma hora de
brincadeira do que em um ano de conversa
a diferença é que agora Platão podemos
ver essas mudanças de forma objetiva no
cérebro da criança academia americana de
Pediatria Sociedade Brasileira de
Pediatria possuímos todos os mostrando
os benefícios da brincadeira com afeto
na formação das habilidades motoras de
inteligência de socialização esses
avanços científicos estão repercutindo
inclusive nos objetivos do
desenvolvimento sustentável do planeta
500 valorizavam apenas mortais o terno
infantil e que a partir de 2015
reconheceram e incluíram investimentos
para melhorar o desenvolvimento infantil
dentro das metas para 2013 alfabetização
aprendizados outra língua vaga na
universidade
Inteligência Emocional desejo de fazer o
Bento capacidade de ter ideias para
serem apresentadas no Ted e para cumprir
os objetivos do desenvolvimento
sustentável do planeta são dependentes
da qualidade da fundação cerebral
construída na primeira infância
interessasse pela ciência do cérebro não
é mais um atributo apenas do cientista
mas sim de todos nós sabemos como
podemos aplicar os princípios para
aperfeiçoar o poder que cada pai e mãe
já trazem no coração é a chave de um
portal de uma nova geração de pessoas
próximas com potencial de transformar o
tudo portanto caminho eles a tradução da
neurociência da primeira infância em
práticas oferecidas com afeto faz com
que a canção máximo do seu potencial
cerebral seres humanos bem sucedidos
intelectual e emocionalmente
Prosperidade que reflete no todo então
Imagine como podemos empoderar toda nova
geração de crianças para que com seus
cérebros forte seus talentos de vida e
suas gargalhadas possam mudar o mundo
brinque ame sorria
gente eu já comecei
vamos comigo
E aí